hallo leute hier wieder eure mal wanne
und heute ist der 18 sechster ein
sonntag und ich mir gleich zum training
von transformers last night train
kleines gewinnspiel rausgehauen und
einige von euch haben gewonnen
geschminkt und gestylt habe ich mich
schon aber ich finde es gibt noch ein
kleines accessoire was zum tag passt und
da habe ich gedacht dass ich mir eine
kleine kette basteln und zwar mit so
einem spielzeugauto
ich finde die dinger ja mega cool und
ich machte mir doch ganz wirklich wenn
ich so eine auto cap betrage also
willkommen zu meinem kleinen lang format
es ist eigentlich ganz einfach ich bin
jetzt ein stück anders auto und dann
habe ich eine kette und dadurch 4
und schon bald fertig schritt nummer
eins wir nehmen uns fehlt ein schneidet
sie einfach mal so eine meine frank
sollte reichen und das klebe ich dann
hier und jetzt hat man das stück wird am
auto dran wenn ihr eine heißklebepistole
hat nimmt eine heißklebepistole ich
mache ein bisschen kleber hier oben
drauf und dann klebt
ich hoffe das wird genau so kommt es mir
vorstelle und jetzt lebe ich den filter
am anderen ende auch noch mal fest und
schön auch den schritt an ein auto
geklebt jetzt packe ich die kette unter
das bild durch wieso habe ich eigentlich
kennen die wainer ich mache so gut man
schon runter klettern
sie findet ihr sieht also ganz ehrlich
ein schönes oder ohne auto könne so
nimmt mich gleich beim pen frühling auf
jeden fall jeder ernst und ich habe noch
mehr auto jetzt die ausnahme bekomme ich
glaube ich brauche den film zu schauen
und wenn ihr wissen wollt was man alles
mit einem fan screening erlebt dann
bleibt jetzt dran
ich bin jetzt im kino angekommen und
natürlich bin ich mit meinem sport wagen
gefahren bin ein verfahren gefahren
oh mein gott
[Musik]
wenn der michael bei michael baar
hierauf werden
[Musik]
eine gruppe libyscher sehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie geht es ins kino rein leere kinos
sind voll cool und mein gott ich bin
hier unten stehen so ein großes kino das
ist nämlich das imax in berlin
hier ist es alles serviert die letzte
reihe wie im bus für die coolen kids
schick ja dann habe ich jetzt richtig
gut gehalten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so seien kleine cello
[Musik]
autos sind eigentlich nicht ganz mein
ding aber witzig war er deswegen habe
ich ganz viel spaß gehabt
[Musik]
wenn ihr noch einen film mit ganz viel
action so richtig schön nach michael
barth mit coolen autos die sich
verwandeln können und die sprechen
können und mit ganz vielen lachern und
ganz viel schmunzeln momenten dann ist
fünfmal so dass man auf jeden fall ein
film für euch seit dem 2 1 ein bisschen
juni ist er draußen also seit gestern
schaut ihn euch an wenn ihr wollt und
verratet mir wie fandet schreibt mir die
kommentare wenn ihnen den gesehen habt
ihr schon gesehen gleich war der gestern
oder heute oder so ein kino prix an eine
sache wollte ich unbedingt noch sagen es
war so cool so viele leute von euch auf
diesen event zu treffen und sich mal
richtig zu unterhalten nicht nur kurzen
foto machen sondern auch mal die leute
kennenlernen die meine videos schauen
und ich muss sagen es ist ziemlich coole
leute die meine videos schauen und wenn
ihr lust habt dass ich so eine
gewinnspiele vielleicht öfter mal mache
schritten auch in die kommentare
dann passiert das vielleicht öfter und
abonniert mich